one other little thing here on the alex
jones verdict a roger stone started
desperately pleading for money for alex
jones
after the
uh 49 million dollar verdict this was
actually um within i think it was within
within minutes
roger stone went on infowars to make an
urgent plea
send alex jones money he needs the money
or this verdict may sink infowars here's
uh here's roger stone
alex jones is a good and decent man he's
a god-fearing christian
he's done more for this movement than
perhaps anyone you can name
and right now
he needs our support there's a place at
the infowars store where you can go just
to make a contribution if you're not in
the market for a book or one of his
great products there's a link where you
can just send a
yeah you can just send money folks it's
that simple so listen
at some point
there has to be some kind of buyer
beware thing okay we talked about this
in the context of
after the 2020 election donald trump
started um asking for money and he
claimed that the reason he was asking
for money was that he was going to fund
audits and he was going to
overturn results and file lawsuits and
all these different things and it
actually said in the fine print hey you
know 50 cents on the dollar or in some
cases even more than that actually goes
to paying off trump campaign debt or
into the coffers or however whatever the
language was that they were using there
um
and then people donated and there was
one rich guy who donated i don't
remember if it was 200 000 or 2 million
dollars and then he sued and he wanted
the money back he said he got scammed
and i don't even know what the outcome
of the case was at this point if after
all this
you go and you donate to alex jones now
at some point you've got to be sol right
s out of luck if you understand what i'm
saying
um at some point i mean if you even just
go to his website and you see the stuff
that's being sold
seed centers and survival accessories
and
various
brain food and uh strange stuff
at a certain point
when you see that
legally the stuff alex jones says is
wrong and defamatory
even if you believe the system is
against him or whatever
wouldn't you have to be smart enough to
realize that if that's the case
maybe it doesn't make sense for you to
be donating money maybe you don't have
to be part of the cause of paying this
49 million settlement now the other
thing i think that bears repeating is
the following
in texas there are limits
to damages
and so the award
may get dramatically reduced
imagine if the award gets reduced to 5
million
and alex jones raises 20
because people think he really has to
pay 49 and then he just keeps the cat i
mean it's not
when your fan base is the people in the
alex jones fan base
it's not completely beyond me that alex
jones might be able to turn this into a
money-making endeavor i i'm not saying
i'm confident that will happen but it's
not completely inconceivable
unbelievable stuff
we all have a responsibility when we're
on the air
and i actually think about what i'm
saying and when i make a mistake
i make every effort to correct it and i
don't target private citizens and all
these different things
um there have to be some limits and it
seems as though alex jones has come up
against those limits